welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Star Wars Episode nine the
rise of Skywalker closes out the
skywalker in the knowledge e word i
didn't know existed before this year
with the return of emperor sheev
Palpatine a mystery tease to us since we
heard him cackling last April which
threw us for a loop considering you know
the old man appeared to croak in Return
of the Jedi the rise of Skywalker is now
in theaters but even those of us who
have seen it are still wondering how
exactly shiva's back what exactly is his
plan and how long exactly has he been
around well let's give this ambiguous
villain the explanation JJ Abrams
frantic pacing didn't that time board
its warning if you haven't seen the rise
of Skywalker yet I just gave you such a
nice padded intro to hit pause on and
that's after you decided to wade into
social media on nerd Superbowl weekend
and like assuming no one would talk
about the nerd score believer it sports
metaphor out of the way first things
first how is Papa ting back Palpatine
did die when Darth Vader tossed him down
the reactor shaft of the second Death
Star in Return of the Jedi now sure we
didn't see a body but something caused
that shaft to burp up a blue blast of
energy and ever since then other than a
few post mortem Operations Center
recordings not a peep from Powell until
the opening crawl of the rise of
Skywalker which proclaims and in so many
words the dead speak and explains how a
recording of the late emperor has spread
across the galaxy warning of The Revenge
kylo Ren recovers one of two Sith
wayfinders following it to the sith
homeworld of EXO Gul and here's the
voice of Palpatine
[Music]
ever inside
I will seize these pods that look like
gestating alternate versions of smoke
and he finds the hooded village of
Palpatine hanging from some kind of
rigging and Palpatine utters a very
important line I have died before the
dark side to the horse is a pathway to
many abilities some time to be unnatural
this perfectly impersonated line is a
direct callback to revenge of the SIS
dark side of the force is a pathway to
many abilities some consider to be
unnatural in this signals to us that
Palpatine's resurrection must have been
connected to what he learned from his
former master Darth Plagueis you ever
hear the tragedy of Darth Plagueis the
wise Darth Plagueis was a Dark Lord of
the Sith so powerful and so wise he
could use the Force to influence the
midi-chlorians to create life he could
even keep the ones he cared about from
dying then his apprentice killed him in
his sleep ironic he could save others
from death but not himself and later in
Revenge of the Sith there was actually a
subtle give away from Palpatine that he
actually did discover plague as his
secret to immortality the Jews did
the power only one has achieved but if
we work together I know we could
discover yeah I remember we'd palp at a
big ol head Cape your hood on but it's
not just darks if magic at play here
Palpatine also resurrected thanks to
genetic engineering yep
cloning has returned to the Star Wars
universe folks some say it never left in
this season the Mandalorian there have
been some clues pointing to Kamino and
strand casts and gene farms it's
everywhere and in certain legends
stories Palpatine cloned himself so that
his soul could repossess a new body
after its death now that history is not
canon but one can see how it may have
inspired the rise of Skywalker in this
film the resistance debates how
Palpatine could have returned
Domenic monoghan Scare achter says Doc's
science cloning secrets only the six
knew now we don't know if this theory is
one that we're meant to take as a
hundred percent legit or just a
speculation by a character who doesn't
really know what's going on but clearly
Palpatine and his minions were engaging
in some kind of genetic experimentation
like if they could construct a GUI
copies of Snoke they could construct GUI
copies of help as Palpatine told kylo he
did die so the weak body that we now see
him occupying must be a reconstructed
genetic copy repossessed by his soul via
the dark side of the force a skill that
he learned from Plagueis but now that
Palpatine is back what is Palpatine's
planned so perhaps the biggest reveal of
this film is that Ray is Palpatine's
granddaughter
apparently she looks he had a kid and
that kid had a kid Rey which I suppose
explains Ray's innate for sensitivity
why she's good at everything
see when Rey was a young girl
resurrected Palpatine sought for that
girl to have a new host body to possess
but her parents hid her on jakku so that
Palpatine would never find her over the
years Palpatine hid in exile in the
Unknown Regions while his supporters
rebuilt a secret fleet of stardestroyers
each equipped with a Death Star super
laser luke skywalker apparently spent
many of his years in exile searching for
Palpatine but he never found him
Palpatine used surrogates likes
nope to control kylo Ren but when Rey
re-emerged from obscurity in the force
awakens' Palpatine adjusted his plan to
now use kylo to try to get Rey to join
the dark side so that the Sith could
live and reign once more inside the
living body of his heir starting with
this film Palpatine's fleet is now
complete and he emerges from the shadows
what was once called the first order is
now called the final order essentially a
fleet of world Enders that could destroy
all planets at once no orders would ever
need to be given again Rey confronts
Palpatine and he goats her into striking
him down so that in a perversion of
obi-wan Kenobi's classic warning to
Vader he could become more powerful than
she could ever imagine
as his Sith essence latches on to raise
anger and inhabits her body but Rey
resists and she's joined by kylo now Ben
solo once more Palpatine sucks some of
their life forces from them to refill
some of his withered body and he uses
supercharged his lightning to destroy
the resistance lead above but nope he
fails his plan fails why other than you
know the movie needs them too well Papa
teens blind-spot was stated perfectly
all the way back in Return of the Jedi
your overconfidence is your weakness
your faith in your friends is yours
Palpatine's the lonely arrogance is
overwhelmed by all of his opponents
little help from their friends
Palpatine assumes having all the Sith
living within him and within Rey would
be an insurmountable power but what he
fails to seize that the Jedi he thought
his oldest 66 had scattered and
destroyed actually continue to live on
with Rey she looks up at the stars and
she says a little prayer and the voices
of all of the Jedi speak down to her to
encourage her we're talking Yoda Luke
obi-wan young and old I think I heard
qui-gon in there definitely heard Anakin
in there mace Windu kanan jarrus ahsoka
tano they can animate a Jedi in there
and now Rey has an army of ghosts at her
back too good ghosts and Maul Sith are
known for betraying each other every
chance they get to the Jedi [ __ ] they
group up they get schools they got
councils they're a Red Rover chain that
never breaks Palpatine needs his
opponents to fear Him it's how he was
able to slay Jedi Masters when they
tried to arrest him his force
paralyzed them but mace windu was not
afraid he nearly killed Palpatine but
Anakin's beer got in the way Luke didn't
fear Palpatine and Return of the Jedi
and that fearlessness led to Palpatine's
defeat and despite appearing scarier
than ever in this film Palpatine is no
match for Ray's strength because she's
got the encouragement of Jedi past
giving her everything she needs and she
takes care of Palpatine exactly as I'm
sure nascent Windu wishes he could have
freaking Anakin not cut his arm off it's
not just a win for a it's a return of
all of the Jedi and a rise but the
skywalker comment down below with your
thoughts on Palpatine's resurrection and
plan and the rise of skywalker
now we've been releasing a bunch of
videos about this movie and explanation
of the ending you're gonna want to check
out and of course a full movie breakdown
of all the Easter eggs you might have
missed follow me on instagram and
twitter at a boss and subscribed into
rock stars for breakdowns of everything
you love thank you for joining me as i
have exhausted myself trying to make
sense of Palpatine's mortality
[Music]